hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The Last
of Us ok so as people were requesting if
they wanted me to not take out my webcam
during the cutscenes because they wanted
to see the raw emotion of horrible tears
that I will be because apparently this
game is so chock-full of fields I'm not
gonna be able to contain myself but
anyway so that's one change that I'm
gonna make and also people said that I
wasn't exploring enough the area and I
thought I was being careful I really
thought I did but it didn't realize that
because I'm so used to games where there
are doors that lead to nowhere but I
guess I was wrong
ooh there seems to be some things here
like this is the sort of stuff that you
guys wanted me to be a new thing these
are parts to upgrade my weapon so these
seems pretty important these seems ok so
I just need to keep a better eye out of
the surrounding area before I start
moving forward like anything shiny I
need to get that she isn't it ok let's
go
ooh I'm not doing so well in the health
department but hopefully I'll be able to
patch myself up later anything here
cinder blocks no thank you
ok I'll follow you to the ends of the
earth no wait no sorry so I won't
because I got my lady back there hello
Tess you do it ok
Mon you seem to be doing pretty well for
a girl that was shot and lots of strong
female lots of strong female characters
in this game excuse me can I get up this
ladder please thank you thank you very
much
alright ter if ok I don't know exactly
where we're going all I know is that
we're trying to run away from the
soldiers we need to find our weapon
cache which I'm assuming is gonna allow
us to be able to make some deal whoa
hello
I felt the rumble in my controllers at
your people what's left ovary why do you
think I'm turning to you guys oh this
way hmm
Tessa and Joel must be a big influence
in this area that even though they've
kind of made their own way been planning
on leaving the city but they need a
scapegoat they were trying to rile us up
just like they did we're trying to
defend ourselves yeah sure whatever you
say lady I don't trust you for a second
it looks like we got more parts here
that I need to scavenge Shiv a ship is a
stealth only weapon that allows you to
take down enemies faster and quieter
than strangling okay so triangle and
triangle to use the ships but they have
limited useless so if I'm alone I should
probably still just try to strangle them
or if there's just one by themselves
all right collecting all the things that
I can and moving forward
yeah sure baby I need a big strong man
no you're a strong independent woman
don't you know man I thought I was silly
but apparently I'm breaking that rule
already so sorry everybody
okay how you holdin up mmm can't we give
you a medkit or something I don't know
if these people know each other from
long ago but oh boy soldiers mm-hmm
that's a way out the door under the
bridge okay
ain't a big fan of these guys we can
sneak by them you know I know that's not
your style
[Music]
what are you trying to sell me you're
saying that I'm not sneaky how dare you
how dare you madam ma'am
okay so I need to get through that door
sneaky like a shadow in the night or a
shadow in the evening more accurately no
one will see a thing as a creep along in
broad daylight no one can see me like a
shadow in the night hello Tess hi well
how come you can crawl creep faster than
I can
hey I'm gonna go in this way because it
seems to be some doors here oh hello
I found one there anyone else there it's
just him okay we're gonna sneak over
grab him spangle him ooh
good teamwork there buddies owls friends
good job everybody
I didn't want to use my shoe because I
thought it would be a waste oh I'm full
on bricks dammit I never knew I could be
full on too many from Oryx I guess even
a badass like myself
has his limits I wonder if there are
ammo caps as well they're usually okay
so we got one guy there and then I know
there's another guy over there I can
barely see his outline but it looks like
just these people okay sneaky sneaky
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneak a wrap
strangling no one can hear a thing and
then there's one more over here man I'm
so glad that all these henchmen are all
facing the same direction who did that's
Oh scheisse uh that would have been bad
okay I'm really I'm trying to be very
careful with how I approach these
situations instead of just guns blazing
or better yet sticks blazing alright so
as soon as that guy moves past I'm
grabbing this guy strangling the piss
out of him oh crap there's a third one
where did he come from you guys don't
see a damn thing
no no no yeah I think running running
running don't have much help oh god I
don't wanna die I'm fine no what
something Cass help please they want to
kill me dead I'm such a big baby you
help me out here Tess
yes sure yeah oh whoops okay so well you
guys aren't gonna alright fine I'll take
care of this now whoa
Oh Oh No
how do I heal myself again totally
forgotten okay pat up hold the triangle
hold there okay here we go all right
healing myself I'm such an idiot
why would I go up against when there
were two guys with a gun why why why
would I do these things why do I do
these things to myself okay where to go
oh he's over there
damn he's mobile that's one thing that
I've noticed about the enemies in this
game they're really mobile like the AI
is pretty damn good on these I like it
Oh Chris I don't have enough bullets to
waste there we go
nice shot markiplier thank you me self
I've arrived
ah yes I am that pathetic okay drop some
ammo six whole bullets thank you very
much okay I need to no need to reload I
need a new stick I've got bricks I need
to use my fabrics can I just do I just
take these bricks and just beam him
right in the head I'm gonna beam him
right in the nards that's what I'm gonna
do that's how I'm gonna do right now
okay I guess I don't need to be sneaky
sure wait a minute hang on just because
people would be angry at me if I didn't
do this is there are these doors open a
bowl is that what these is I have no
idea what's an open Abul door for
scavenge of all materials or not so I'm
kind of running in the dark here but I'm
gonna try to keep moving forward
houki I don't need a bottle I get a
break do I have unlimited bricks noise
just one brick I can use it as many
times as the one I'm getting jeez lady
I'm trying it's doing the best I can
damn nice where are we going Marlene to
find some guns this way it's not far now
yeah lady are you sure you don't need a
med kit I mean I know you're a badass
and all that way tougher than I am but I
mean I I think I have one to spare right
here okay all right you're too tough I
get it
you're strong independent woman and I'm
just Joel the old man cuz I don't know
how old Joel was in the beginning of it
what about us that killed a bunch of
soldiers curfew this really does remind
me of city 17 in half-life except that
the curfew isn't you know isn't a
robotic voice by GLaDOS that was voiced
by the same person by the way Ellen
McLain she did the voice for the city 17
announcements as well as GLaDOS
important and she did a few boys she did
the team fortress voices for oh sorry
yes I'll help you with my big strong
arms he also did the Team Fortress
announcer this let her go young [ __ ]
what happened don't worry this is
fixable
I got his help
but I can't come with our the user
reaction you wanted to see
well then I'm staying oh we won't get
another shot at this hey we're smuggling
her there's a crew of fireflies it'll
meet you at the capital building
that's not exactly close you're capable
you hand her off come back the weapons
are yours double what Robert sold me
speaking of which where are they back in
our camp
we're not smuggling [ __ ] until I see
them you'll follow me you can verify the
weapons I can get patched up but she's
not crossing to that part of town
I went Joel to watch over her how do you
know them
I was close with his brother tommy said
if I was ever in a jam I could rely on
him was that before or after he left
your little militia group he left you
too he was a good man I could just take
her to the north tunnel and wait for me
there he's just cargo Joel Hartley no
more talking you'll be fine
now go with him don't take long and you
stay close let's go
yeah oh man I'm so excited man I gotta
say the graphics in those cutscenes
especially are really damn good I mean I
think those are real time I'm a nerd
when it comes to graphics I I love
technology and stuff like that so you'll
occasionally see me spazzing out about
these swords Oh
what happened we killed people eyes yeah
oh no way today is gonna happen to us if
we don't get off the street okay yeah
that's right so you pay attention to me
and follow me trying to find one of
these rooms that might possibly be
salvageable could I steal parts out of
these bicycle like people are really
like emailing me that very angrily that
was like hey wow you said you were gonna
be very careful but you're just blowing
past everything I'm like this is how I
would normally play the game if I was by
myself I'm not that meticulous when I
play so I'm really trying I'm really
trying these doors are all fake you're
all lying to me but you liars
I'll pick up stuff that is kind of out
of the way but I won't go exploring
absolutely everything everywhere okay
donkey thank you announcer lady who is
mysteriously talking to be from nowhere
Ellie was the same name of the girl in
Dead Space 3 right even the young girl
is a badass I can already tell she's
totally awesome
wait is this door open evil
I'm not saying I just like strong female
Kirk's I like strong characters in
general like ones with personality
you're not just dumb faceless soldiers
that could be replaced by anyone you
know people with actual charisma up
there to the north tunnel okay
just give me a minute to find her oh
okay this seems easy enough see take
this dumpster yeah I'm so strong it's
reminds me the only other PlayStation 3
game is I played was God of War so in my
favor when I was lugging around stuff
like that mmm you impressed I would be
thank you okay so now yump there we go
easy enough can you jump up little girl
Oh what oh you can't make that jump Oh
what are you a giant baby whip oh you
can't make it God come on come on okay
is she coming up or what hey little girl
little girl Ellie come on yeah finally
slowpoke alright sometimes no that's a
first about time you caught up anyway
what's the deal with you and Marlene
anyways I can't run in here she's my
friend your friend you're friends with
the leader of the fireflies what are you
she knew my mom and she's been looking
after me and I'm 14 not that that has
anything to do with anything
where are you where anyone's parents
they've been gone a long long time
mm-hmm so instead of just staying in
school you decide to run off and join
the fireflies now there are schools in
this apocalypse while you're smuggling
me if that's what you're getting at
don't know the best thing about my job I
don't gotta know why be honest with you
I give two shits what you're up to
yeah yeah
good it's great way to talk to a kid
Joel cheese I know you're insensitive
but come on
well says the guy that was just
ridiculing her for not being able to
clean up a bad thing but goddamnit Joel
be nicer to her
just cuz she's so lazy and wimpy and
weak yeah whatever sorry I'm an asset I
think the original actor for Ellie was
supposed to be Ellen Page or whatever
name is but she did beyond two souls
instead so they couldn't do both I don't
see why not
you can't kind of see some resemblance
in the face they had to change the model
in every what are you doing
killing time well what am I supposed to
do I'm sure you will figure that out
your watch is broken
[Music]
oh no it is Joel's got to be about fifty
by now right because when he was had a
kid and her kid his kid was probably
about ten or twelve so he's got to be
yeah
you know I've never been this close it's
the outside look how dark it is can't be
any worse out there
can it hmm what on earth to the
fireflies one with you hey sorry it took
so long about time how's Marlene she'll
make it
I saw the merchandise it's a lot do this
yeah yeah alright can do I'm ready
alright so apparently we're going out of
this city which means that we're gonna
reach outside because when I when I
first saw the game I didn't see much of
the city life so I'm assuming that most
of the game was spent outside and if I'm
not mistaken it's a bit stir it's in
Pennsylvania I think Marlene wanted to
do it herself
you weren't their first choice or the
second for that matter she's lost a lot
of men beggars can't be choosers mm-hmm
let's just hope there's someone to pay
all righty
whatever you say Tess I really hope
something doesn't happen to test I've
got this bad feeling because people
around Joel seem to just kind of die so
I would hate I don't I don't want to say
anything I don't wanna jinx anything I
just want to be not pessimistic about
anything it's probably gonna be like
what am I doing here
hey do it yeah oh oh yeah God look at me
go so great yeah so awesome I could have
gotten on the first try but I just
didn't want to don't judge me
don't judge me little girl waiting for
us at the drop love she said there's
some fireflies
away from another city you're almost be
important what is the deal with you you
some bigwigs daughter or something
something like that
is she immune if everything goes as
planned we should get you to them in a
few out all right whatever you say
yep of course imagine that everything's
about to go south real soon
believe there be a zombie ambush or the
soldiers are gonna come out of nowhere
put those things all right we're good
come on up you would think that in 20
years the zombies would die out but man
how they've been staying alive watch
your step I mean obviously these aren't
the undead type of zombies but even so
after a while it's really good wouldn't
be able to survive but then again what
do I know why aren't you guys sneaking
I'm creeping along like a shadow in the
night and you guys are just to do to do
to do whatever screw you guys I don't
look stupid I'm perfectly awesome
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
they're looking at me like what that
what the hell is wrong with you Mark
Clark dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
I'm sorry
overly dramatic probably dun dun dun dun
okay where are we going oh through here
alright I'm an idiot this way yeah still
creeping along you guys just stand up
like I'd open targets whatever whatever
I don't care I don't care
do I look like I care the answer is I do
not ah come on
it was so obvious oh yeah I knew
something was gonna happen scan him
Oliver
put your hands on your head this is
Ramirez at sector 12
requesting pickup for three stragglers
understood mmm no way I'm gonna make it
worth your while
shut up so everyone has chips in their
head that look really great
whoa damn little girl way to be a badass
oh god damn I thought we were just gonna
hold them up or something [ __ ] look
what
uh-huh
oh they were scanning for the effects it
iced up why the hell are we smuggling an
infected girl she is immune no which is
why I can explain you better explain
fast look at this I don't care how you
got infected it's three weeks old to
know everyone turns within two days so
you stop bullshitting it's three weeks I
swear why would she set you up someone
was bound to be immune at some point
that's just the way nature works
well this is where things go south
because as soon as they find the dead
shoulders it's all gonna be bad follow
me no speaky speaky like a shadow in the
night
CQ like a shadow in the night give me a
while I just walk all over you guys
don't mind right guys don't mind has
don't mind me being here you ran out dub
you come on you lion test right I'm
gonna run wait is me runner her run I
don't know which one of us was supposed
to run so we just got to be very careful
here ok we'll do my best but no
guarantees here I'm bad at stealth stuff
loot seriously whenever I try to do
something like this it just goes
horribly awful for me Jess what happened
what does he okay are you infected holy
crap Gus what the hell is a sprint ready
all right so we're gonna ignore that
test whatever happened there no do not
check the chances to stay back sorry
Ellie just get up on the damn wall we're
just like a horribly organised
everything everything in the wrong si le
pas le what are you doing
le what are you doing what are you doing
le le are you okay you okay le le you
don't look pretty good okay
all right Ellie they didn't see anything
like a shadow in the night okay you
don't see a thing buddy
very stealthy I am nothing at all oh
come on you didn't see anything no
nothing nothing at all
total your eyes lied you you just fired
it water I'm such an idiot
you guys okay back there okay good good
good to hear I hope there wasn't
anything scavenger Bowl because I went
right past it I can see them up ahead
squeeze down way down all that wasn't
fair you're just gonna ignore that you
were shooting at everything right
shooting it anything at all how can I
brick this guy in the damn face I'm
still alive somehow holy crap I am NOT
this game I'm not good at this game
everyone ignore it how bad I am
performing right now and just keep in
mind that I am not good at anything no
I'm a good game shut up girl here I'm
surprised that they just so readily
ignore than anything happened over here
wait hang on let me see if there's
something over here scavenger ball head
ow look I'm being mindful of my
surroundings I found tape cool is that
good all right it's good huh okay open
this up
holding triangle look at how strong I am
at home bloody I am they shot me like 13
kinds Thank You Tess okay this time I'm
actually gonna be through this section
very carefully okay
getting down very still we'll go this
way
it's pilotis yet let's go around we're
being safe it's not good hello
same thing in there nothing you just
brick
see if you can distract with this brick
okay I need to distract him out that
window that's where I need to go up
BRAC that was not smart okay oh my God
look at that wall keep looking keep
looking at that wall that was so
interesting isn't it they didn't see
anything nope nope nope nope nope nope
not happening nope not gonna happen go
this way maybe this way I'm going the
wrong way
excuse me well I just run in a circle
for a little bit Ellie you still want
this Ellie probably died a long time ago
yes you got any idea which way uh-huh
see where this leads
okay get in there get in there man get
in there we're doing just fine
even though I panic at the slightest
provocation I am doing just fine
everybody I don't need your criticism
thank you very much hey close I would
think that the rain would be able to
hide you a little better but apparently
not okay yeah it's like there might be
some scavenger bulls around here
somewhere where are we squeezing through
exactly what you guys looking at what
are you looking at some oh here okay
follow me yeah more soldiers oh man why
are they out in such force for just a
small incident I mean we did kill two of
their friends I guess but be very
careful very carefully I wonder how they
managed to secure a whole city I mean I
am seriously curious as to what sort of
government is set up in this place that
they're able to maintain such order I
mean obviously they're pretty corrupt I
would guess but it's got to be some ah
here we go
a mother lode no don't punch them
Joel seriously don't eat any of your lip
they're still around
let's take a moment to catch your breath
it's challenging to everything we can
use in here I got the straps is there a
gun or something a shotgun would be
lovely ammo and that one cool alright
doing good so far umm well where do we
go from here those are another way out
here Yes No maybe so okay looks like
definitely no so we're gonna go this way
actually we're pretty much out of time
for this part so things are going pretty
well for me even though I messed up some
stealth situations I still haven't died
yet so haha there's that even though I'm
playing uh normal so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
there we go